hello and welcome to Simply loans
YouTube channel in this carefully
curated video we are going to discuss
the field of cyber security in extensive
detail we will cover some highly sort
after topics like cyber security skills
salary of a cyber security professional
at various stages of their career and
then we will discuss some of the most
important cyber security certifications
you must pursue if you want to be top
company so let's in the ever evolving
digital landscape of 2024 where
technology propels Our Lives forward the
need for cyber Warriors has never been
more pronounced as we delve into this
year the realm of cyber security
promises challenges opportunities and a
chance to make a real difference if you
have ever pondered the path of becoming
a guardian of the digital realm 20124
might just be the year to set your
course in this era data is not just
information it's power and with great
power comes great responsibility cyber
Security Professionals are the guardians
of this power the Vigilant Sentinels of
our Digital Society as you embark on
your journey to become a cyber security
professional you will not only be
acquiring a set of skills but also
embracing a mission safeguarding the
Digital Universe from the ever advancing
forces of cyber threats whether you are
a noce interviewed by the world of cyber
security or a seasoned it professional
looking to specialize the road ahead
offers exciting prospects in this guide
we will navigate the intricate network
of knowledge skills and experiences
required to become a cyber security
professional in 2024 from understanding
the latest trends to mastering the
basics we will equip you with the tools
and insights to embark on a secure and
promising future in this Dynamic field
and before starting if you are an
aspiring cyber security professional
looking for online training and
certification from prestigious
University
and in collaboration with leading
experts to enhance your credibility then
search no more simply learn postgraduate
program in cyber security from MIT
University in collaboration with EC
Council should be your right choice and
this course is designed to accommodate a
diverse range of Learners and this
course requires just a bachelor's degree
with a 50% average and no prior
programming experience and one plus year
of work experience is preferred for more
details you can use the link mentioned
in the description box and pin comment
so fasten your seat belts and let's
embark on this journey together your
mission to secure the digital world of
2024 we'll start with who is a cyber
security professional so cyber security
professional is an expert dedicated to
safeguarding digital systems and data
they defend against cyber threats assess
risk respond to incidents and ensure
compliance with security standards
ethical hackers test system and they
play pivotal roles in securing the
digital Realm through constant learning
and evolving strategies so this is the
person or this is the cyber security
professional and now we'll see the roles
and responsibilities for the particular
category so roles and responsibilities
for a cyber security professional so the
starting is security monitoring
continuously monitor systems and
networks for potential security threats
and suspicious activities so these are
the roles and responsibilities for a
cyber security professional moving to
the next that is incident response so
cyber Security Professionals develop and
execute plans to respond to security
incidents containing and mitigating the
impact of breaches moving to the next
that is vulnerability assessment
identify and assess vulnerabilities
within systems and networks and
prioritize them for remediation and
moving to the next that is security
compliance ensure compliance with legal
and Industry specific cyber security
regulations and standards so now we we
will move to the next roles and
responsibilities so these are access
control that is Implement and manage
access controls to limit unauthorized
access to critical resources and then we
have security architecture that is
design and Implement security measures
including firewalls encryption and
intrusion detection systems and then we
have security awareness educate
employees about security best practices
to reduce human related security risk
and then we have penetration testing
conduct ethical hacking to identify and
address weaknesses in security systems
so these are some of the roles and
responsibilities of a cyber Security
Professionals and they do a very very
very pleora of roles and
responsibilities on different job roles
now we'll see the steps to become a
cyber security professional so we'll
start with the number one step that is
Educational
Foundation so establishing a strong
Educational Foundation is fundamental
for becoming a cyber security expert
obtaining a bachelor's degree in fields
like computer science or cyber security
provides Essential Knowledge and Skills
forms the basis for more specialized
cyber security training and
certification programs setting the
groundwork for a successful career in
the field so this was about the
Educational Foundation now moving to the
step two that is cyber security
courses so you can also enroll in
specialized cyber security courses and
certifications and they will help you
crack the more certif apption that is
certified information system security
professional cissp certified ethical
hacker CH and certified information
security manager cism and coma Security
Plus and here we have a simply learn
postgraduate program in cyber security
from MIT University in collaboration
with EC Council and that should be a
right choice if you want to crack all
the certifications this course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and this course requires
just a bachelor's degree with a 50%
average and no programming experience
required and one plus year of work
experience is preferred in any field for
more details you can use the link in the
description box below now moving to the
third step that is Hands-On learning so
Hands-On learning in cyber security
involves practical Real World experience
it includes setting up security systems
conducting penetration test analyzing
malware and responding to simulated
cyber incidents this Hands-On approach
is crucial for developing the skills and
intuition needed to address security
threats effectively so this was the step
three now moving to the step four that
is networking so networking in the
context of becoming a cyber security
expert involves building professional
relationships within the cyber security
Community it includes attending industry
events joining forums and connecting
with experienced experts these
connections provide opportunities for
knowledge sharing mentorship and staying
updated on the latest trends and threats
in the field which are essential for
career growth and expertise so now
moving to the step
five that is ethical hacking skills
ethical hackers also known as Whitehead
hackers specialize in Legally and
proactively identifying vulnerabilities
and weaknesses in systems and networks
they use their skills to simulate cyber
attacks uncover security flows and
provide recommendations to strengthen
defenses ethical hacking is essential
for maintaining robust cyber security by
preventing malicious experts so this was
about the step five now moving to the
step six that is stay informed
continuously update your knowledge by
following cyber security blogs attending
webinars and subscribing to Industry
Publications staying informed about the
latest threats vulnerabilities and
security Trends is essential in the ever
evolving field of cyber security
enabling you to adapt and protect
against emerging risk so now moving to
the the step seven that is internships
and entry-level jobs internships and
entry-level jobs in cyber security
provides invaluable Real World
Experience they offer Hands-On exposure
to security tools processes and best
practices these positions allow
individuals to apply their knowledge
work alongside experienced professionals
and develop practical skills setting the
foundation for a cyber security
successful career and now moving to the
next step that is step eight and that is
specialized domain specializing in cyber
security involves focusing on a specific
area within the field such as Network
Security application security or
incident response by deepening your
expertise in a particular domain you
become better equipped to address
specialized threats and challenges
making you a valuable asset in the cyber
security landscape now moving to the
Step n that is
certifications certifications are vital
in the cyber security Journey they
validate your expertise and open career
opportunities start with foundational
certifications like coma Security Plus
and progress to Advanced ones such as
cissp or cism these credentials showcase
your knowledge and commitment to
potential employers making you a more
attractive candidate for cyber security
roles now I'll just tell you about the
list of popular cyber security
certifications number one is cissp that
is certified information security system
security profession
and this demonstrates expertise in
information security and is highly
recognized globally then we have
certified ethical hacker that focuses on
ethical hacking and penetration testing
preparing professionals to identify and
address vulnerabilities then we have
cism certified information security
manager that validates skills in
managing and governing an Enterprise
information security program and then we
have cisa certified Information Systems
AO then that focuses on auditing control
and Assurance skills for information
systems and then we have coma Security
Plus an entry level certification
covering foundational security skills
and knowledge and then we have ccsp
certified Cloud security professional
that specializes in Cloud security
demonstrating expertise in securing
Cloud environments and then we have
cissp issap that is certified
information security technician that
concentrates on our architecture
emphasizing risk management and
governance and then we have cism
certified information security manager
that validate skills in managing and
governing and Enterprise information
security program and then we have ccsp
certified Cloud security professional
that specializes in Cloud security
demonstrating expertise in security
Cloud environments and we have a list of
all the certified cyber security
certifications but these are the top of
the main certifications which you can
pursue now moving to job roles and
average salary so the first job role we
have is information security manager and
the average salary for this particular
role is
$150,000 in us and for in India that is
11 lakhs perom and then we have the next
job role that is cyber security engineer
and the average salary for this role in
US is
$145,000 per year and in India that is
13 lakhs perom and then we have the next
role that is application security
engineer and for this role the average
salary in US is
$12,000 and in India that is 10 lakhs
perom and then we have network security
engineer and the average salary for this
role is
$156,000 in us and in India that is 8
lakhs perom and then we have cyber
security analyst and for this role the
average salary in US is
$115,000 perom and in in India that is 7
lakhs perom and now moving to the
companies hiring cyber security
professionals so the companies are
Amazon ass senture Google Apple and
Intel so these are the top most
companies that hire cyber Security
Professionals and every company needs
cyber Security Professionals to
safeguard their systems and to defend
the customers identities or their
credentials and this was all about for
this tutorial hope you guys found it
informative and and helpful if you are
an aspiring cyber security professional
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more we have
simply learned Advanced executive
program in cyber security in
collaboration with npci and that should
be your right choice with this program
you can transform your career in 6
months for India specific region only
this course provides a high engagement
learning experience with real world
applications and is designed for
individuals who want to start a new and
more fulfilling career hey everyone
welcome back to another video by simply
learn today we are diving into the
exciting world of cyber security we
protecting valuable data and information
is more crucial than ever but before we
jump into the essentials of cyber
defense let's first understand what
cyber security is before moving forward
let me ask you a quick question so which
of the following is not an example of
common cyber security threat option A is
fishing option b is malware option C is
firewall or option D is ransomware you
can pause this video and answer in the
comment section below all right so now
let's begin with the first topic that is
what is cyber security so cyber security
refers to the practices and Technologies
used to protect computers networks and
digital information from unauthorized
access theft damage or disruption it is
like digital lock and a key system that
keeps your personal and sensitive
information safe from hackers and other
cyber threats just like you lock the
doors of your house to keep the thieves
out cyber sec security keeps hackers out
of your digital world it involves things
like using strong passwords keeping
software up to date and being cautious
when opening email attachments and
clicking on the links the cyber security
Market size is expected to reach 400
billion by 2028 as per Global Market
insights organizations and businesses
also have a responsibility to implement
cyber security measures to protect their
customers data and prevent cyber attacks
that could harm their reputation and
financial stability some of the popular
companies with a very high demand of
cyber security Engineers are semantic
rapid 7 fire ey Microsoft and calfire
Etc now career scope of cyber security
the career scope of cyber security is
vast and ever expanding due to the
increasing Reliance on technology and
growing threat of cyber crime cyber
Security Professionals are in high
demand across various Industries and
sectors including government Finance
Healthcare e-commerce and Technology the
demand for cyber Security Professionals
is expected to continue to grow as organ
organizations increasingly prioritize
protecting their data and systems from
cyber threats now let's talk about a
topic that's on everyone's mind that is
cyber security salaries there are
various roles in the field of cyber
security each with its own
responsibilities and corresponding
salary ranges let's discuss some common
cyber security roles and their
approximate salary ranges first is
ethical hacker ethical hackers are cyber
security professionals who are
responsible for accessing the security
of computer systems networks
applications and other digital assets to
identify vulnerabilities they perform
authorized legal and controlled hacking
activities to file vulnerabilities and
report them to the organization for
remediation the average salary of an
ethical hacker is around 16 lakhs in
India and $888,000 in the United States
next is security engineer a security
engineer plays a critical role in
ensuring the security and integrity of
an organization Information Systems
networks and data their responsibilities
typically include designing and
implementing security measures
monitoring and detecting security
breaches Etc the average salary of a
security engineer is around 8 lakhs in
India and
$120,000 in the United States next up we
have Chief Information Security Officer
the Chief Information Security Officer
or ciso is a senior leadership role
responsible for overseeing the
organization's information security
strategy policies and programs the ciso
is accountable for ensuring the
confidentiality Integrity of the
organization information protecting them
from cyber security threat the average
salary of a chief information security
officer is around 76 lakhs in India and
$186,000 in the United States the next
role is network security engineer a
network security engineer is responsible
for managing and securing the
connections and communication between
devices computers over the Internet they
play a crucial role in implementing and
maintaining security measures that
Safeguard network connections and ensure
the protection of sensitive information
transmitted over the Internet the salary
of a network security engineer is around
6 lakhs in India and
$101,000 in the United States now moving
on to the next role that is it security
specialist an IT security specialist
collaborates with the team of it
professionals to create strategies and
plans for safeguarding devices and
systems within organization against
cyber attacks they conduct assessments
of the it systems to identify potential
onear abilities and work with the team
to strengthen the security posture of
the organization's it environment the
average salary of an IT security
specialist is around 12 laks in India
and $112,000 in the United States so
these are the various roles in the cyber
security and along with these there are
many other roles also next we have is
certification required for this field so
there are numerous certifications like
cyber security expert master program
certified information security manager
CCH cyber security boot camp offensive
security certified professional and EJ
ptv2 Etc now let's have a look at them
first is cyber security Masters program
this master's program in cyber security
will provide you with all the necessary
skills to excel in the rapidly expanding
field of cyber security through this
comprehensive program you will learn how
to safeguard your infrastructure by
implementing robust measures to protect
data and information conducting through
risk analysis and mitigation designing
cloud-based security systems ensuring
compliance and much more next is
certified information security manager
offered by the information system audit
and Control Association C cism is
certification that validates an
individual's expertise in information
security governance risk management and
information security program management
following is Caltech cyber security boot
camp by simply learn this Caltech cyber
security boot camp will help you gain
the skills and experience required by
the organization to protect their
critical systems and sensitive data from
cyber attacks through real world
projects in just 26 weeks this boot camp
will help you develop expertise in both
defensive and offensive cyber security
digital forensics penetr ation testing
infrastructure design and much more the
course curriculum labs and assisted
practices expose you to several in
demand cyber security tools next up we
have is offensive security certified
professional offered by offensive
security OSP is a certification that
focuses on offensive security skills
including ethical hacking penetration
testing and exploit development it
requires Hands-On practical skills and
is known for its challenging
certification exam next is Advanced
executive program in cyber security by
simply learn this course provides a high
engagement learning experience with real
world applications and is designed for
individuals who wants to start a new
more fulfilling career this Advanced
executive program in cyber security will
help you develop expertise in defensive
cyber security application malware
analysis ethical hacking Etc this cyber
security program developed in
collaboration with triple ID Bangalore
and npci helps you gain a strong
understanding of identifying potential
opportunities for innovation in cyber
security industry moving on to the next
certifications that is EJ ptv2
certification is a welld designed to
access your Proficiency in all stages of
penetration testing life cycle including
assessment methodologies host and
networking auditing host and network
penetration testing Etc its exam
includes 35 questions and you need to
score at least 70% to pass you have a
48h hour time frame to complete it so
these were some of the best
certifications that you can opt for all
right guys with that we have come to the
end of this video if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up I hope it
really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including d data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here